it's time now for CBS deals this morning
we've got a few things that just might
make your day a little easier and could
help you get a jump on those holiday
deals with items that are for all year
long at home or when you're on the Go
and all at exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or you can visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Gail bass
joins us now with all the details Gail
good morning to you good morning to you
Dana and good morning to everybody who's
in the kitchen now chopping up and doing
stuff for like almost time of year it is
that time of year and if you want to up
your knife game the caloric Cobra series
is perfect okay we have three knives
they're super sharp there's carbon steel
and because they're carbon steel they
hold that sharpness longer chefs now in
the kitchen are talking about this kind
of knife and look how sharp that is this
is a big old chunk of Ginger that that's
sliced right through very beautiful set
of knives this is great for that person
who wants to up their kitchen game or
somebody who's got their first apartment
and doesn't can't afford expensive
knives we have these for 37 off for 38
dollars that's a fantastic deal on
knives what's our next item our next
item is great this is the react Escape
tool this is for everybody who drives a
car this is a great stocking stuffer
okay this little device if you see it
right here I'm going to show it off yeah
right there you have a light you have a
phone charger but you also have a seat
belt cutter the great thing about this
is if you're trapped in an accident this
will cut a seat belt and break a window
okay it also has a little bit of an
emergency sound I'm gonna play that
right there there you go and it also has
a flashlight and flashing lights so and
you can also charge your phone this is a
great device so much in one yeah and you
want to have this in your car this is
the go-to tool for your car and you're
not going to lose it because you're
going to keep it in the car to help
charge your phone how much is this one
this we have for 50 off it's
24.99 and remember this is a good
stocking stuffer because apparently
there's some holiday coming up something
coming up somebody told me something
about something now I love this one this
is from Rush charge we have two from
Rush charge and this one is a flash
speaker so you've got a speaker right
there but what I love about this one is
the fact that you know mosquitoes look
at me as a 7.99 steak buffet in Las
Vegas
I am like I'm like a chocolate fountain
for toddlers at a wedding this thing if
you look at this I love it it has a
strobe light it has a dancing light but
it also has this red light now this
looks yellow on TV but this is a red UV
light that will repel mosquitoes but you
also want to have this in your car when
you go camping it's a great safety tool
that people should have for themselves
multi-purpose is multi-purpose and think
about you could charge your phone with
this and you can I mean and the fact
that if you're in an emergency and you
see an accident and you've called 9-1-1
it's got a huge strobe so you could flag
down you can flag down firefighters so
they know exactly where you are how much
is this one this one is a great price
this one is 74.99 you're gonna want this
one it's 50 off and how about on the end
this is the must-have for anybody who
likes to go camping you like to go on a
picnic there's so many uses for this
this is for people at home this is for
the handyman handy woman this is the
rush charge power station okay it could
charge your hot plate it can inflate a
tire an air bed if you are out of power
for a couple of days just think about
all the natural disasters that we have
and people are out of power if you have
a power outage at your home in the
summer this can power a 12 volt small
refrigerator for two days it could
charge all kinds of phone devices this
is the must-have tool in your house or
in your RV when you go camping my
boyfriend's looking at that like we like
to Camp we'll get it let me use that
absolutely because you can put your hot
plate plug it in there make crepes and
the price on this one the price on this
one 500 off this is 8.99 this is the
must have item for your home all great
Gail thank you and don't forget we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head over to cbsdeals.com